bentornato a "Capire l'informazione e il calcolo quantistico", mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico per l'educazione
di IBM Quantum. Questa è la nona lezione della serie ed è la prima lezione della terza unità, dedicata alla formulazione generale
dell'informazione quantistica. Fino ad ora abbiamo usato la formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica dove gli stati quantistici sono rappresentati da vettori complessi con norma euclidea pari a
uno. Al contrario, nella formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica gli stati quantistici sono rappresentati da
matrici di un certo tipo, note come matrici densità. Questa prima lezione dell'unità si concentra sulle matrici densità in modo specifico
e capiremo cosa sono e come funzionano nel corso della lezione. Le matrici densità sono estremamente
utili e offrono vari vantaggi di cui parleremo. Ci permettono di rappresentare una
classe più ampia di stati rispetto ai vettori di stato quantistico, compresi gli stati di sistemi che sono stati influenzati dal rumore per esempio, nonché selezioni casuali
di stati quantistici. Daremo anche un'occhiata alla sfera di Bloch, che ci offre un modo geometrico molto bello
e semplice di pensare agli stati di un qubit, e vedremo come si collega alle matrici densità in un modo
piuttosto notevole attraverso le matrici di Pauli. Infine, discuteremo le matrici densità nel contesto di sistemi multipli
e in particolare vedremo come ci permettono di descrivere gli stati quantistici di sistemi visti in isolamento, anche quando
sono correlati con altri sistemi, inclusa la possibilità che siano entangled con altri sistemi. Questa è una cosa importante da poter
fare e non è facilmente realizzabile nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica. Ecco una panoramica della
lezione: inizieremo con le basi delle matrici densità, incluse le definizioni rilevanti e alcuni esempi, e
discuteremo anche come si collegano ai vettori di stato quantistico. Parleremo poi delle combinazioni convesse di matrici densità, ovvero
in altre parole cosa succede quando calcoliamo medie ponderate di matrici densità. Inizieremo con un esempio specifico
del cosiddetto stato completamente misto. Vedremo come gli stati probabilistici classici possono essere visti come
casi speciali delle matrici densità e discuteremo come il teorema spettrale dell'algebra lineare entra in gioco in
questo contesto. La terza parte della lezione riguarda la sfera di Bloch, che fornisce un modo geometrico per visualizzare gli stati di
singoli qubit come ho accennato all'inizio della lezione. Nella quarta parte della lezione parleremo di come le matrici densità funzionano per sistemi multipli
discuteremo gli stati prodotto e gli stati correlati di vario tipo, inclusi gli stati entangled, nonché
la nozione di stato ridotto, che è una descrizione con matrice densità dello stato di una parte isolata di un sistema composto
che può essere calcolata usando un'operazione nota come traccia parziale. Prima di arrivare ai contenuti tecnici della lezione,
è opportuno dedicare qualche momento per motivare l'uso delle matrici densità. Usando la formulazione semplificata
dell'informazione quantistica, che non prevede le matrici densità, siamo in grado di descrivere algoritmi quantistici come
l'algoritmo di fattorizzazione di Shor per esempio, senza alcuna difficoltà. Quindi perché dovremmo preoccuparci delle matrici densità
o di questa formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica? Beh, ci sono molteplici ragioni. Prima di tutto, le matrici densità
rappresentano una classe più ampia di stati quantistici rispetto ai vettori di stato quantistico, inclusi gli stati quantistici in cui abbiamo incertezza o
casualità. Questo è importante quando vogliamo modellare gli effetti del rumore sui calcoli quantistici per
esempio. In secondo luogo, usando le matrici densità possiamo descrivere gli stati quantistici di parti isolate di sistemi composti, come
gli stati di sistemi che sono entangled con altri sistemi che forse momentaneamente scegliamo di ignorare, come ho accennato all'inizio della
lezione. Questo non è facilmente o naturalmente realizzabile nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica.
Una terza ragione è che quando usiamo le matrici densità l'informazione classica emerge effettivamente come un
caso speciale. Quindi invece di avere quella che è essenzialmente un'analogia tra stati probabilistici e operazioni da
un lato, e vettori di stato quantistico e operazioni unitarie dall'altro, abbiamo l'informazione quantistica e classica
descritte insieme all'interno di un unico framework matematico, il che è praticamente essenziale per lo studio matematico
dell'informazione quantistica. Quindi se sei seriamente intenzionato a comprendere l'informazione quantistica a livello matematico, è altamente
raccomandato che tu impari le matrici densità. Iniziamo con la definizione di matrici
densità. Ai fini della definizione, supponiamo che X sia un sistema e sigma sia il suo insieme di stati classici, e ricorda che
quando usiamo questa terminologia la nostra assunzione è che Sigma sia finito e non vuoto e, come sempre, potremmo scegliere
nomi diversi se volessimo. Una matrice densità che descrive uno stato del sistema X è una matrice con
elementi numerici complessi le cui righe e colonne sono state messe in corrispondenza con il suo insieme di stati classici, e per essere chiari
è la stessa corrispondenza per le righe e le colonne simultaneamente. Questo significa che le matrici densità
sono sempre matrici quadrate e, oltre ad essere quadrate, ci sono un paio di condizioni che devono essere
soddisfatte e le vedremo a breve. Le persone di solito usano certe lettere greche minuscole per denominare le matrici
densità: ρ è spesso la prima scelta e altre scelte comuni includono σ minuscola e τ che sono mostrate
sullo schermo. Questa è solo una convenzione ma, come al solito, queste convenzioni sono utili perché rendono le cose più
facilmente riconoscibili. Ora parliamo delle condizioni o dei requisiti che le matrici densità devono soddisfare per essere
matrici densità valide. Ce ne sono due e quello che farò è prima semplicemente elencarle
e poi le discuterò in maggior dettaglio. La prima condizione è che le matrici densità
devono avere traccia unitaria, ovvero traccia uguale a uno. La seconda condizione è che le
matrici densità devono essere semidefinite positive e in entrambi i casi abbiamo modi simbolici concisi per esprimere
queste due condizioni che appaiono sullo schermo. Ora lascia che discuta le due condizioni in maggior dettaglio.
La prima condizione si riferisce alla traccia, che è una funzione molto importante definita per tutte le matrici quadrate
ed è semplicemente la somma degli elementi diagonali. Ecco un'equazione che esprime questo
esplicitamente. Ora c'è molto da dire sulla traccia e sul perché è importante, ma per ora osserviamo
solo una proprietà molto basilare: è una funzione lineare. Altre proprietà della traccia emergeranno e le discuteremo
quando necessario, ma per mantenere il focus sulle matrici densità passiamo al secondo requisito, ovvero che le
matrici densità siano semidefinite positive. Questo è anche un concetto importante che emerge in molti contesti in
fisica, chimica, ottimizzazione, machine learning e altre materie e può essere espresso in diversi modi ma equivalenti tra loro.
WEBVTT
fisica, chimica, ottimizzazione, machine learning e altre materie, e può essere espresso in diversi modi ma equivalenti tra loro.
Un modo per esprimerlo è dire che una matrice ρ è semidefinita positiva se esiste una matrice M tale che ρ è uguale a M dagger per M, e si scopre che non importa se richiediamo che M stessa sia una
matrice quadrata o se lasciamo cadere questa restrizione. Un altro modo per esprimere cosa significa per una matrice ρ essere semidefinita
positiva è dire che ρ è hermitiana, ovvero uguale alla propria trasposta coniugata, e che tutti i suoi autovalori sono numeri reali non negativi. In generale le matrici hermitiane possono
avere solo autovalori reali, ma possono essere negativi, ma se includiamo la restrizione aggiuntiva che nessuno degli
autovalori può essere negativo otteniamo le matrici semidefinite positive. E a proposito, se ti viene data
una matrice e vuoi sapere se è semidefinita positiva puoi determinarlo usando questa caratterizzazione. È abbastanza facile
verificare se una matrice è hermitiana: è qualcosa che si può vedere a occhio. È più difficile calcolare
gli autovalori, ma non è troppo difficile farlo con un computer perché esistono algoritmi molto efficienti per farlo.
L'ultima caratterizzazione che menzionerò, sebbene ce ne siano altre, è che per ogni vettore colonna s avente
un numero di elementi che concorda con il numero di righe e il numero di colonne di ρ, la disuguaglianza mostrata sullo
schermo è vera. In parole, bra-s per ρ per ket-s deve essere un numero reale non negativo.
Non è ovvio, tra l'altro, che queste caratterizzazioni siano tutte equivalenti, ma lo sono. E lascia che noti esplicitamente che la
notazione che comunemente usiamo per indicare che una matrice ρ è semidefinita positiva sembra ρ maggiore
o uguale a zero, ma questa è solo una notazione abbreviata e non significa letteralmente che ρ è maggiore di
o uguale a zero. ρ è una matrice, quindi non avrebbe senso. E non significa
che ciascuno degli elementi di ρ è maggiore o uguale a zero. In particolare ci sono matrici semidefinite positive i cui elementi non sono tutti non negativi
e ci sono matrici i cui elementi sono tutti non negativi ma non sono semidefinite positive. L'idea alla base della notazione è che le matrici semidefinite positive
sono come analoghi matriciali dei numeri reali non negativi, ma questa è solo notazione e ciò che significa è
precisamente quello che abbiamo già discusso. Ora diamo un'occhiata ad alcuni esempi, iniziando con un esempio di una
matrice semidefinita positiva. In effetti, è abbastanza facile generare casualmente un esempio di una matrice semidefinita positiva
semplicemente scegliendo una matrice M arbitrariamente e poi calcolando M dagger per M. Per esempio, ecco una matrice M che non è particolarmente speciale, e in effetti
l'ho generata casualmente scegliendo in modo indipendente le parti reali e immaginarie degli elementi come interi tra -9 e
9, quindi eventuali pattern o strutture qui sono puramente casuali. Moltiplicando la
trasposta coniugata di M per M otteniamo questa matrice, che è quindi semidefinita
positiva. Ovviamente c'è un limite a quanto possiamo capire da un esempio casuale, ma mostra alcune
caratteristiche comuni alle matrici semidefinite positive in modo più generale. In particolare noterai
che gli elementi diagonali, cioè quelli lungo la linea dall'angolo in alto a sinistra all'angolo in basso a destra, sono tutti numeri reali non negativi.
Inoltre gli elementi fuori diagonale non sono troppo grandi rispetto ai corrispondenti elementi diagonali,
ovvero quello nella stessa riga e quello nella stessa colonna dell'elemento fuori diagonale che stiamo considerando.
C'è però di più in questa storia, ed è importante riconoscere che essere semidefinita positiva è una
proprietà di una matrice nel suo complesso e non solo una condizione sui singoli elementi. Questo era un esempio di una
matrice semidefinita positiva e puoi generare molto facilmente altri esempi attraverso una metodologia simile.
Ora diamo un'occhiata ad alcuni esempi di matrici densità dove, in aggiunta alla condizione semidefinita positiva, abbiamo anche che la traccia è
uguale a uno. Ecco alcuni esempi di matrici densità 2×2. La traccia è uguale a
uno in tutti e quattro i casi e possiamo anche vedere che queste sono matrici hermitiane, quindi usando la seconda caratterizzazione delle
matrici semidefinite positive di prima, tutto ciò che rimane è verificare che gli autovalori siano tutti non negativi.
Lo lascio come esercizio se vuoi. Per le matrici 2×2 non è troppo difficile calcolare gli autovalori a mano,
ma puoi anche chiedere a un computer di farlo, per esempio puoi usare la funzione eigvals nel pacchetto di algebra lineare
per Python. Possiamo anche ottenere una matrice densità semplicemente prendendo qualsiasi matrice semidefinita positiva non nulla
e dividendola per la sua traccia. Per esempio, ecco la matrice densità che otteniamo
dividendo l'esempio che abbiamo visto poco fa per la sua traccia. Dividere per la traccia in questo modo
preserverà sempre la proprietà semidefinita positiva e otterremo certamente una matrice con traccia uguale a uno in virtù del fatto che
la traccia è una funzione lineare. Questa è solo una piccola raccolta di esempi e ne vedremo altri nel corso della
lezione. Successivamente prendiamo qualche momento per discutere l'interpretazione o il
significato intuitivo delle matrici densità. La prima cosa da riconoscere è che può sembrare un po' insolito
rappresentare lo stato di un sistema con una matrice piuttosto che con un vettore. Al contrario, nella formulazione semplificata
dell'informazione quantistica usiamo vettori per rappresentare gli stati mentre le matrici, specificamente le matrici unitarie,
rappresentano azioni o operazioni. Questo è semplicemente il modo in cui funziona la matematica e, sebbene tu possa
sempre pensare alle matrici come descrizioni di mappe lineari, di solito non associamo un significato intuitivo diretto
alla mappa lineare associata a una data matrice densità. Detto questo, il fatto che
le matrici densità siano effettivamente matrici si rivela essere un aspetto criticamente importante di esse, come vedremo
man mano che andiamo avanti. Ma per menzionare brevemente solo un esempio per ora, gli autovalori di una data matrice densità
si rivelano molto importanti perché descrivono quanta casualità o incertezza è intrinseca nello stato
che quella matrice densità descrive. Un modo diverso di pensare alle matrici densità a livello intuitivo
si concentra sugli elementi di queste matrici. Ricorda che le righe e le colonne delle matrici densità sono messe
in corrispondenza con gli stati classici di qualunque sistema stiamo considerando. Quindi per ogni elemento abbiamo uno
stato classico corrispondente alla riga di quell'elemento e uno stato classico corrispondente alla colonna di quello
stato. Per gli elementi diagonali quei due stati classici sono lo stesso stato, ed è per questo che gli elementi diagonali sono
speciali. Un modo per interpretare gli elementi diagonali è che sono probabilità, e specificatamente sono
le probabilità che il corrispondente stato classico apparirebbe se effettuassimo una misura nella base standard
WEBVTT
sul sistema il cui stato quantistico stiamo descrivendo. Per gli elementi fuori diagonale invece abbiamo uno stato classico corrispondente alla riga
di quell'elemento e uno stato classico diverso corrispondente alla colonna di quell'elemento, e molto informalmente parlando
questi elementi descrivono il grado in cui questi due stati classici sono in sovrapposizione quantistica, nonché la
fase relativa tra loro. Questo potrebbe avere più senso man mano che la lezione prosegue e guardiamo più
da vicino ad alcuni esempi specifici, e i dettagli potrebbero non essere chiari a questo punto, ma ti prego di non lasciartene
turbare. Questo è abbastanza informale ed è solo un'idea intuitiva da tenere a mente.
Successivamente daremo un'occhiata al collegamento tra le matrici densità e i vettori di stato quantistico, che sono vettori colonna
con norma euclidea uguale a uno. Solo per richiamare la definizione matematica: supponendo di avere un
vettore di stato quantistico ψ che rappresenta lo stato di un dato sistema, la matrice densità che rappresenta lo stesso
stato quantistico è data da ket-ψ per bra-ψ come mostrato qui sullo schermo. Per essere chiari su questo, gli indici di ψ
corrispondono in qualche modo agli stati classici di qualunque sistema stiamo considerando, e questa sarà precisamente la stessa corrispondenza che abbiamo tra
le righe e le colonne della nostra matrice densità e gli stati classici del sistema. Se immaginiamo che ci siano n
stati classici del sistema e pensiamo ai vettori colonna e riga come matrici, allora ket-ψ è una matrice n×1
e bra-ψ è una matrice 1×n, quindi quando eseguiamo la moltiplicazione otteniamo una matrice n×n.
Questa sarà sempre una matrice semidefinita positiva per la sua forma, e avrà anche traccia uguale
a uno in virtù del fatto che ψ è un vettore unitario, come vedremo in maggior dettaglio
a breve. Gli stati quantistici rappresentati da matrici densità di questa forma sono chiamati stati
puri. Ecco alcuni esempi. Prima consideriamo questo stato
qui, che è un po' come lo stato plus tranne che l'elemento corrispondente allo stato classico uno è
immaginario. Se calcoliamo la trasposta coniugata raccoglieremo un segno meno perché il coniugato complesso di i è
meno i, e se eseguiamo la moltiplicazione otterremo la matrice mostrata qui sullo schermo. È hermitiana come possiamo
vedere immediatamente guardandola, e ha un autovalore uguale a uno e un autovalore uguale a
zero, quindi è semidefinita positiva, e la sua traccia è uguale a uno, quindi è una matrice densità come
previsto. Possiamo calcolare le matrici densità corrispondenti alle basi standard e plus-minus in modo simile, e quelle matrici densità
sono mostrate qui. Ed ecco un altro esempio di vettore di stato quantistico che è apparso
molto indietro nella prima lezione della serie e, se calcoliamo la trasposta coniugata e poi moltiplichiamo,
otterremo la matrice densità mostrata qui. Ancora una volta è hermitiana e ha
traccia uguale a uno e, se calcoli gli autovalori, troverai che di nuovo ha un autovalore uguale a uno e uno uguale a
zero. Tra l'altro questa è una caratteristica comune di tutti gli stati puri: hanno sempre un autovalore uguale a uno
e il resto degli autovalori sono tutti zero. In generale, per un vettore di stato quantistico completamente arbitrario
ψ con qualsiasi numero di elementi, se moltiplichiamo ket-ψ per bra-ψ otterremo una
matrice densità che ha questo aspetto. Nota in particolare che gli elementi diagonali sono sempre uno degli elementi
di ψ moltiplicato per il proprio coniugato complesso, che possiamo esprimere alternativamente come il modulo quadrato di quell'elemento, e questo è
un modo per vedere che la traccia sarà sempre uguale a uno. È anche coerente con l'osservazione che ho fatto prima nella lezione riguardo
agli elementi diagonali di una matrice densità che ci dicono quali sarebbero le probabilità di vedere ogni possibile stato classico
se eseguissimo una misura nella base standard. E un'ultima osservazione:
non c'è nessun problema riguardo alle fasi globali per le matrici densità. Due stati quantistici sono identici se e solo se le loro matrici densità
sono uguali. In particolare supponiamo di avere due vettori di stato quantistico ψ e φ che
sono equivalenti a meno di una fase globale, il che significa che possiamo esprimere uno di essi, diciamo φ, come l'altro per
un numero complesso sul cerchio unitario. Se calcoliamo la rappresentazione in matrice densità di φ, quello che troveremo
è che il fattore di fase globale viene moltiplicato per il proprio coniugato complesso e questo ci dà uno, quindi
scompare effettivamente e rimaniamo con esattamente la stessa matrice densità che otteniamo da ψ. Questo è in un certo senso un
bel piccolo bonus, e più in generale non c'è nessun problema riguardo all'equivalenza a meno di fasi globali quando stiamo
lavorando con le matrici densità. Questo è fondamentalmente solo una degenerazione che esiste quando usiamo i vettori di stato quantistico piuttosto
che le matrici densità per rappresentare gli stati quantistici. Le matrici densità possiedono una proprietà chiave, ovvero che le combinazioni convesse
di matrici densità rappresentano selezioni probabilistiche o casuali di stati quantistici.
Un altro modo per dirlo è che le matrici densità possono essere mediate insieme in modo significativo, il che non è
qualcosa che possiamo fare con i vettori di stato quantistico. Per spiegare questo in maggior dettaglio, iniziamo con la situazione in cui
abbiamo due matrici densità ρ e σ che rappresentano stati quantistici di un certo sistema. Immaginiamo che il
sistema venga preparato nello stato ρ con probabilità p per una certa scelta di p tra zero e uno, e altrimenti il sistema
viene preparato nello stato σ. Per esempio forse p è 1/2, quindi
potremmo immaginare che qualcuno lanci una moneta equa e se viene testa esegue un certo processo che lascia il sistema nello
stato ρ, e altrimenti se la moneta viene croce esegue un processo diverso che lascia il sistema nello
stato σ. La domanda ora è qual è lo stato del sistema, e per essere chiari
siamo interessati allo stato del sistema in isolamento, prescindendo da qualsiasi altra informazione che potrebbe esistere su
quale preparazione è stata eseguita. Per esempio, immagina che non abbiamo accesso alla moneta o alla
memoria di chiunque abbia eseguito la preparazione dello stato. E la risposta a quella domanda è che è semplicemente la media ponderata delle due matrici densità
p per ρ più (1−p) per σ. Questo tra l'altro è completamente
analogo a quello che avremmo se ρ e σ non fossero matrici densità ma fossero piuttosto vettori di probabilità
che rappresentano stati probabilistici. Quindi questo non è qualcosa di scioccante o misterioso, ma piuttosto è qualcosa
che forse è familiare dalla teoria delle probabilità. Facciamo questo tipo di media continuamente quando calcoliamo probabilità e pensiamo
a selezioni casuali classiche. Il punto è che questo funziona anche per le matrici densità, ma nota che non
funziona per i vettori di stato quantistico. Cioè non puoi generalmente mediare due vettori di stato quantistico
in questo modo sperando di ottenere un vettore di stato quantistico valido, e se ci provi di solito otterrai un vettore che
non ha norma euclidea uguale a uno. Con le matrici densità invece le medie ponderate come questa saranno sempre
matrici densità valide e, cosa più importante, la matrice densità che ottieni rappresenterà quella selezione casuale in
modo significativo. Questo si generalizza a selezioni casuali in cui ci sono più di due
alternative. In particolare se abbiamo M possibili matrici densità e un vettore di probabilità con M elementi, uno
per ogni matrice densità, e un sistema viene preparato in ciascuno dei possibili stati con la probabilità corrispondente,
allora la media ponderata di quelle matrici densità descrive lo stato risultante del sistema. E a proposito, quando
ci riferiamo a una combinazione convessa di matrici densità questo è ciò che intendiamo: una combinazione convessa è semplicemente una combinazione lineare
in cui i coefficienti formano un vettore di probabilità. Questa sarà sempre una matrice
densità, e un modo semplice e conciso per dirlo in termini matematici è che l'insieme di tutte le matrici densità
corrispondenti a un dato sistema è un insieme convesso. Quindi se abbiamo, diciamo, m vettori di stato quantistico
ψ₀ fino a ψ_ insieme a probabilità p₀ fino a p_ che collettivamente formano un
vettore di probabilità, e un sistema viene preparato nello stato ψ_k con probabilità p_k per ogni k, allora lo
stato risultante del sistema è descritto dalla matrice densità mostrata qui sullo schermo. In particolare non stiamo facendo la media
dei vettori di stato quantistico stessi, ma piuttosto facciamo la media delle corrispondenti matrici
densità. In generale uno stato come questo non avrà una rappresentazione come singolo vettore di stato quantistico
a meno che non stia succedendo qualcosa di banale, come ad esempio tutti i vettori di stato quantistico sono equivalenti a meno di una fase globale o tutti tranne uno delle
probabilità sono zero. Non otterremo uno stato quantistico puro da un tale processo, ma piuttosto otterremo quello che si chiama
uno stato quantistico misto, in cui c'è un'incertezza intrinseca. Diamo un'occhiata a un semplice
esempio: supponiamo di avere un qubit e con probabilità 1/2 il qubit viene preparato nello stato zero, e altrimenti
viene preparato nello stato plus. Ecco la matrice densità che otteniamo facendo la media come ho
descritto: calcoliamo le matrici densità corrispondenti ai due possibili stati, moltiplichiamo per le probabilità corrispondenti e sommiamo i
risultati. Quello che otteniamo è effettivamente una matrice densità: è hermitiana, la sua traccia è uguale a uno
e, se calcoli gli autovalori di questa matrice, otterrai due numeri reali positivi che dovrebbero probabilmente esserti familiari
ormai: coseno quadrato di π/8 e seno quadrato di π/8, ovvero circa 0.85 e
0.15. Non esiste una singola rappresentazione come vettore di stato quantistico per questo stato: non è uno stato puro. Successivamente daremo un'occhiata a una
particolare matrice densità che rappresenta uno stato quantistico di un singolo qubit noto come stato completamente
misto. Questo stato ricorre frequentemente quindi è bene avere un nome per esso, ed è anche un buon esempio perché
illustra una caratteristica importante delle matrici densità. Esiste in effetti uno stato completamente misto definito analogamente per qualsiasi
sistema, ma per ora ci concentreremo su questo stato per un singolo qubit solo per mantenere le cose
semplici. Supponiamo di impostare casualmente lo stato di un qubit allo stato zero o allo stato uno, ciascuno con
probabilità uguale a 1/2, molto come un bit casuale uniforme. Possiamo calcolare la rappresentazione in matrice densità di questo
stato nel modo solito: prendiamo la media delle due rappresentazioni in matrice densità degli stati. Ecco come
appare in forma matriciale e quello che otteniamo è la matrice identità divisa per
due. Questo stato è noto come lo stato completamente misto e rappresenta fondamentalmente un'incertezza completa o massimale
su un qubit, proprio come un vettore di probabilità uniforme rappresenta l'incertezza massimale nell'impostazione
probabilistica classica. In generale, per un sistema arbitrario, lo stato completamente misto è lo
stato che si ottiene scegliendo uniformemente uno stato della base standard, e la rappresentazione in matrice densità sarà la
matrice identità divisa per la dimensione o equivalentemente il numero di stati classici di quel
sistema. A questo punto questa è solo terminologia, ma se modifichiamo un po' la configurazione vedremo una caratteristica importante delle
matrici densità. In particolare, supponiamo di cambiare la procedura e al posto degli stati della base standard
zero e uno sostituiamo gli stati plus e minus. Questa volta iniziamo con l'espressione
mostrata sullo schermo, ma se facciamo i calcoli otteniamo esattamente la stessa
matrice densità: è la matrice identità divisa per due. Quindi è lo stesso stato di prima, lo
stato completamente misto. Questo, come si suol dire, è una caratteristica e non un bug. Le due procedure sono in realtà
diverse, ma se tutto quello che hai è il qubit risultante non c'è modo fisico in cui tu possa possibilmente distinguerle,
nemmeno in senso statistico. Per esempio, se eseguissi una misura nella base standard su questo qubit
dopo che la prima procedura fosse stata eseguita, otterresti ovviamente l'esito zero con probabilità 1/2 e l'esito uno con probabilità 1/2, ma otterresti anche
esattamente le stesse probabilità di esito per la seconda procedura. E lo stesso vale per qualsiasi altro test che potresti
escogitare, supponendo che tu stia testando solo il qubit stesso. In generale le matrici densità non descrivono come un sistema è stato
preparato, ma solo cosa accadrà se fai delle cose a quel sistema in futuro, che si tratti di eseguire
operazioni o misurazioni. E in effetti le matrici densità sono perfette in questo
senso: se due alternative diverse risultano nella stessa matrice densità, non possono essere discriminate nemmeno
statisticamente. Ma se le due matrici densità sono diverse, ci sarà un modo per discriminarle, non
necessariamente in modo definitivo, ma in senso statistico. Quando usiamo la formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica
l'informazione classica emerge essenzialmente come caso speciale, e ora spiegherò come funziona.
Specificamente vedremo come gli stati probabilistici possono essere rappresentati da matrici
densità. Iniziamo con gli stati classici, partendo da un esempio semplice.
Ecco le rappresentazioni in matrice densità degli stati della base standard zero e uno di un
WEBVTT
qubit. Associamo questi stati agli stati classici 0 e 1 e quindi possiamo pensare a queste matrici densità come
rappresentazioni di quegli stati. Questo è molto semplice e possiamo facilmente generalizzare l'
esempio. Se abbiamo un sistema il cui insieme di stati classici è Σ, allora lo stato classico a è rappresentato da o
associato alla matrice densità ket-a bra-a. Quella matrice ha un singolo uno nell'elemento
diagonale la cui riga e colonna corrispondono allo stato classico a e ogni altro elemento è
zero. Gli stati probabilistici sono rappresentati da combinazioni convesse di matrici di questa forma, il che è naturale
dato quello che sappiamo sulle matrici densità e su come funzionano. Specificatamente le combinazioni convesse di matrici densità rappresentano selezioni casuali o
probabilistiche di stati quantistici. Per esempio, supponiamo di avere
un sistema X il cui insieme di stati classici include gli interi da 0 a n−1 per qualche intero positivo n. Ovviamente
c'è poca o nessuna perdita di generalità nell'assumere che il nostro insieme di stati classici abbia questa forma. Se avessimo un
insieme di stati classici diverso potremmo semplicemente rinominare gli stati classici in questo modo, ed è spesso abbastanza conveniente fare l'assunzione che i nostri
insiemi di stati classici abbiano questo aspetto, in gran parte perché rende più facile scrivere le cose esplicitamente in termini di
vettori e matrici. Supponendo di avere uno stato probabilistico del sistema X
rappresentato da un vettore di probabilità nel modo solito, possiamo associare questo stato probabilistico a una matrice
densità come mostrato sullo schermo. Prendiamo la media ponderata delle matrici densità corrispondenti ai
diversi stati classici e quello che otteniamo è una matrice densità diagonale. In particolare vediamo le probabilità
lungo la diagonale di questa matrice e ogni altro elemento è uguale a zero. Ovviamente questa è una matrice densità:
ci aspettiamo che sia così, ma possiamo anche ragionarlo direttamente. È una matrice hermitiana, la sua traccia
è uguale a uno perché le probabilità sommano a uno, e nel caso di una matrice diagonale gli autovalori sono gli elementi diagonali
e sono tutti non negativi perché sono probabilità. Nota anche che ogni
matrice densità diagonale, cioè quella i cui elementi fuori diagonale sono tutti zero, deve avere questo aspetto. Quindi in sintesi
gli stati probabilistici possono essere associati a matrici densità diagonali. Nota tra l'altro che questo è coerente con
l'interpretazione informale degli elementi delle matrici densità che ho menzionato all'inizio della lezione. In particolare nulla è in
sovrapposizione quantistica qui: è fondamentalmente solo casualità classica, e corrispondentemente tutti gli elementi fuori diagonale
sono zero. In precedenza in questa serie abbiamo discusso il teorema spettrale, e lo abbiamo fatto
specificamente per le matrici unitarie nel contesto della stima della fase. Il teorema spettrale è più
generale di così, però, nel senso che ci dice qualcosa su una classe più ampia di matrici rispetto alle sole matrici unitarie.
In particolare si applica a una classe di matrici chiamate matrici normali, che includono tutte le matrici hermitiane
nonché le matrici unitarie. Quello che faremo ora è dare un'occhiata a un enunciato diverso di questo teorema, questa volta concentrandoci sulle sole
matrici semidefinite positive, e poi vedremo che ci dice qualcosa di molto interessante e criticamente importante sulle matrici
densità. Supponiamo che P sia una qualsiasi matrice semidefinita positiva, quindi include qualsiasi matrice densità nonché qualsiasi
matrice semidefinita positiva che non abbia traccia uguale a uno. P è semidefinita positiva quindi deve essere
quadrata, ovvero n×n per qualche scelta di n, e dovremo fare riferimento a quel numero n, quindi sia N scelto
appropriatamente. In altri termini, assume P è n×n. Quello che il teorema ci dice in questo caso è che
deve esistere una base ortonormale di vettori che chiameremo ψ₀ fino a ψ_, insieme a numeri reali non negativi
λ₀ fino a λ_, tali che P possa essere espressa come mostrato
qui sullo schermo. In parole, se moltiplichiamo ogni λ_k per ket-ψ_k per bra-ψ_k e poi
sommiamo su tutti i k da 0 a n−1 otterremo P. Questa si chiama decomposizione
spettrale di P. Ogni λ_k è necessariamente un autovalore di P e ogni ψ_k è un autovettore unitario di P
corrispondente a quell'autovalore. Se guardi alla lezione 7 sulla stima della fase troverai un teorema simile
per le matrici unitarie. Lì gli autovalori sono numeri complessi sul cerchio unitario piuttosto che essere numeri reali non negativi,
ma per il resto è la stessa idea, e questi sono in realtà solo due casi speciali di un teorema più generale noto come
teorema spettrale. Non funziona per ogni matrice: è necessario che la matrice commuti con la propria
trasposta coniugata, e questo è ciò che significa per una matrice essere normale. Ma in effetti lo abbiamo sempre
sia per le matrici unitarie che per le matrici semidefinite positive, e per le matrici hermitiane più in generale dove
avremo sempre autovalori reali ma non necessariamente non negativi. Questo era l'enunciato del
teorema spettrale per le sole matrici semidefinite positive, e ora vediamo cosa ci dice sulle matrici
densità. Quello che ci dice è che per una qualsiasi matrice densità n×n possiamo sempre esprimere quella matrice come una combinazione convessa
di n stati puri e, inoltre, possiamo prendere quegli n stati puri come
ortogonali. Questo segue abbastanza direttamente dal teorema insieme a un fatto basilare dell'algebra lineare, ovvero che
la somma degli autovalori di qualsiasi matrice è sempre uguale alla traccia di quella matrice. In altre parole stiamo davvero solo
rinominando gli autovalori p₀ fino a p_ e poi osservando che quando facciamo questo e
raccogliamo quegli autovalori in un vettore di dimensione n otteniamo necessariamente un vettore di probabilità, perché devono essere tutti non negativi e la loro somma è uguale
alla traccia di ρ che è uno perché ρ è una matrice densità. Quindi è abbastanza semplice, ma è
davvero fondamentale concettualmente. Quello che ci dice è che ogni matrice densità, per quanto complicata possa sembrare, potrebbe derivare dalla selezione prima di una base ortonormale del sistema
di cui stiamo parlando, e poi dalla scelta casuale di uno stato quantistico da quella base secondo una certa scelta per le
probabilità. Se non è immediatamente chiaro perché questo sia interessante o importante, va bene, ma usiamo questo
fatto molto frequentemente quando ragioniamo sulle matrici densità, e in effetti esprimere una data matrice densità in
questo modo è spesso la primissima cosa che facciamo quando vogliamo capirla
meglio. Ecco un esempio: ricordiamo la matrice densità che abbiamo calcolato prima dove scegliamo casualmente tra
lo stato zero e lo stato plus, ciascuno con probabilità 1/2, che come abbiamo calcolato ha una matrice densità che
WEBVTT
ha questo aspetto. Lo stato zero e lo stato plus non sono ortogonali, quindi questa non è una
decomposizione spettrale. Ma se ne calcoliamo una, il che possiamo fare con un computer o a mano in un caso come questo, allora quello che
otteniamo è questa espressione della nostra matrice densità dove gli autovalori sono questi numeri che continuano a comparire e
dove i corrispondenti autovettori possono essere scelti come mostrato qui in basso sullo schermo. E di nuovo abbiamo visto questi vettori prima, per esempio nel
contesto del gioco CHSH nella lezione quattro. Quindi secondo la
espressione originale questo stato è ciò che si ottiene scegliendo uniformemente tra due stati: lo stato zero e
lo stato plus. Ma in realtà otteniamo esattamente la stessa matrice densità scegliendo casualmente tra due stati
puri, con una preferenza molto forte verso uno di essi: circa l'85% per il primo e solo circa il 15% per
il secondo. Quindi in un certo senso c'è in realtà meno casualità intrinseca nello stato di quanto potrebbe sembrare inizialmente.
C'è un modo geometrico molto bello per pensare e visualizzare gli stati quantistici di un singolo qubit, noto
come sfera di Bloch. Funziona solo per singoli qubit. Per sistemi con tre
o più stati classici, inclusi due o più qubit insieme, non funziona più, quindi è abbastanza limitato. Ma
tuttavia è un ottimo modo per pensare agli stati di un singolo qubit. Avrebbe potuto essere introdotto
già nella prima lezione della serie sui sistemi singoli, ma non è davvero essenziale per capire come funziona l'informazione quantistica e ha anche un
collegamento davvero bello con le matrici densità, quindi si inserisce naturalmente in questa lezione. In effetti lo spiegherò
in un modo un po' diverso da come viene tipicamente spiegato, usando le matrici densità per derivarlo
in modo efficace. Quindi se hai già familiarità con la sfera di Bloch questa spiegazione potrebbe essere un po' diversa da come
l'hai imparata la prima volta, ma alla fine dovrebbe ovviamente essere equivalente. Inizieremo pensando
ai possibili stati puri di un qubit prima, come rappresentati da vettori di stato quantistico.
A meno di una fase globale, ogni vettore di stato quantistico di un qubit può essere espresso come
mostrato qui sullo schermo. Per essere precisi abbiamo due numeri reali θ e φ e penseremo
a questi due numeri come angoli espressi in radianti. Il primo numero θ è compreso tra 0 e π, ovvero equivalentemente è un
angolo tra 0 e 180°, e il secondo numero φ è compreso tra 0 e 2π, incluso 0 ma non 2π,
quindi è qualsiasi angolo tra 0 e 360°. L'elemento zero del nostro vettore è
il coseno di θ/2, quindi è un numero reale tra 0 e 1 e in particolare è necessariamente non negativo.
L'elemento uno del nostro vettore è e^ per il seno di θ/2 e può essere
qualsiasi numero complesso sul cerchio unitario complesso o al suo interno. Questo è sempre un vettore unitario, ovvero
in altre parole è un vettore di stato quantistico valido. E per qualsiasi dato vettore di stato quantistico di un qubit possiamo sempre trovare
un vettore di questa forma che sia equivalente a quel vettore a meno di una fase globale. In particolare possiamo sempre
moltiplicare il vettore dato per una fase globale per rendere l'elemento zero un numero reale non negativo, scegliere il valore di
θ che ci dà quell'elemento, e poi scegliere φ per corrispondere all'elemento uno. Il modulo dell'elemento uno concorderà sempre
necessariamente con il seno di θ/2 dall'assunzione che siamo partiti da un vettore unitario.
Ora non è proprio il caso che θ e φ siano univocamente determinati dal vettore di stato quantistico da cui siamo partiti,
ma è quasi così. Ci sarà sempre un unico valore di θ tra zero e π che funziona
e di solito c'è un unico valore di φ che funziona, ma in due casi speciali non è così. In particolare se siamo partiti da uno
stato della base standard, allora θ sarà zero o π, e in entrambi i casi non importa davvero quale sia φ: è
completamente irrilevante. Quando θ è zero il coseno di θ/2 è 1 e il seno di θ/2
è zero, quindi stiamo moltiplicando e^ per zero, quindi non fa alcuna differenza qual è φ.
E se θ è π allora questa volta il coseno è zero e il seno è uno, quindi abbiamo e^ per ket-1, ma questi
vettori sono tutti equivalenti a meno di una fase globale, quindi anche in questo caso non importa quale sia φ. Tuttavia se θ giace strettamente
tra 0 e π ci sarà sempre un unico valore di φ che funziona. E tra l'altro questa possibile
degenerazione nel valore di φ per i due casi speciali avrà perfettamente senso quando vedremo il quadro geometrico tra
poco. Ora calcoliamo la matrice densità associata a un vettore di stato della forma che abbiamo appena
identificato. Questo sarà dunque uno stato puro di un qubit. Per farlo moltiplichiamo il vettore
per la sua trasposta coniugata come di consueto, e sullo schermo c'è un'espressione della matrice che otteniamo calcolando la
trasposta coniugata ed eseguendo la moltiplicazione. Ora, proprio come ogni matrice 2×2,
c'è un modo unico per ottenere questa matrice prendendo una combinazione lineare delle matrici di Pauli,
inclusa la matrice identità. In particolare possiamo ottenere questa matrice scegliendo i coefficienti delle
matrici di Pauli come mostrato qui sullo schermo. Stiamo mettendo un due al denominatore perché questo farà funzionare
tutto bene: niente ci costringe a farlo, ma possiamo farlo ed è utile. Ma a parte
questa scelta cosmetica non c'è libertà: questo è l'unico modo per ottenere questa matrice prendendo una combinazione lineare delle matrici di Pauli, perché
le matrici di Pauli inclusa la matrice identità formano una base per lo spazio vettoriale di tutte le matrici 2×2. Un modo
per verificare la correttezza di questa espressione è fare uso di alcune identità trigonometriche di base e in particolare se mi sposto un momento
qui abbiamo alcune identità che faranno al caso nostro. Quindi se sei incline metti in pausa il video o
fai uno screenshot e vedi se riesci a ottenere la seconda espressione della matrice densità in basso a partire dalla prima. Quindi in sintesi qualsiasi stato puro di un
qubit espresso come matrice densità può essere scritto come combinazione lineare delle matrici di Pauli come mostrato sullo
schermo per θ tra 0 e π e φ tra 0 e 2π. Nota che abbiamo precisamente la
stessa degenerazione di prima: φ è irrilevante quando θ è zero o π. E questa volta possiamo effettivamente
vederlo più chiaramente perché il seno di θ è zero in quei due casi, mentre altrimenti non lo è. Vale la pena notare
che in questa formula θ appare come argomento delle funzioni seno e coseno piuttosto che θ/2 come nella versione originale del vettore di stato quantistico, e questo è perché abbiamo usato quelle identità trigonometriche le prime tre delle quali sono fondamentalmente
riarrangiamenti delle cosiddette formule del doppio angolo. Quindi l'angolo viene effettivamente raddoppiato. E ora siamo finalmente pronti per
WEBVTT
parlare della sfera di Bloch. Concentriamoci sui tre coefficienti delle matrici di Pauli non identità
al numeratore dell'espressione della nostra matrice densità. Quindi stiamo ignorando il due al
denominatore e stiamo anche ignorando la matrice identità perché il coefficiente di quella non cambia mai: questo accade perché quel
coefficiente è determinato dalla traccia di qualsiasi matrice che stiamo esprimendo, e le matrici densità hanno sempre traccia uguale
a uno. Ora immagina di avere tre assi etichettati x, y e z orientati secondo
la cosiddetta regola della mano destra, e considera il punto le cui coordinate corrispondono ai tre coefficienti. E per essere chiari questo è
il normale spazio tridimensionale di cui stiamo parlando, dove le coordinate sono sempre numeri reali. La
coordinata x corrisponde al coefficiente della matrice di Pauli σ_x al numeratore della nostra espressione, che è sempre un numero reale perché le matrici
densità sono hermitiane, e lo stesso vale per y e z. Quello che troviamo è che questo punto che
otteniamo si trova sempre sulla sfera unitaria, ovvero la sfera con raggio uguale a
uno. In particolare è il punto che si ottiene se si parte dal punto in cui l'asse z positivo interseca la sfera,
che possiamo pensare come il Polo Nord, si ruota verso il basso verso l'asse x positivo di un angolo θ e poi
si ruota verso l'asse y positivo, ovvero verso Est, di un angolo φ. In questo contesto l'angolo θ si chiama
angolo polare, che è facile da ricordare perché parte dal polo, e φ si chiama angolo
azimutale. Insieme questi due angoli rappresentano le coordinate sferiche per i punti sulla sfera unitaria, e se
volessi potresti anche permettere al raggio di variare per rappresentare punti arbitrari nello spazio tridimensionale, ma qui ci stiamo concentrando sui punti sulla
sfera unitaria dove il raggio è uguale a uno. Puoi anche pensare a θ come che rappresenta la latitudine tranne che andiamo
da 0 a 180° dal Polo Nord al Polo Sud piuttosto che da più o meno 90° dall'equatore, e φ rappresenta
la longitudine dove definiamo fondamentalmente il meridiano primo come il meridiano che interseca l'asse x positivo.
Se sei come me, a proposito, e hai difficoltà a ricordare quale sia la latitudine e quale la longitudine, può essere utile ricordare
che la longitudine corrisponde all'intervallo più lungo: 2π rispetto a
π. Comunque, il punto che otteniamo sulla sfera unitaria dal nostro vettore di stato quantistico ψ pensando alle coordinate in questo
modo è la rappresentazione sulla sfera di Bloch dello stato quantistico corrispondente a ψ, e quando pensiamo all'intera
sfera unitaria tridimensionale in questo modo otteniamo la sfera di Bloch. Geometricamente è solo una sfera unitaria
nel normale spazio tridimensionale, ma in effetti questa è la geometria degli stati di un qubit.
C'è una corrispondenza biunivoca perfetta: ogni stato puro di un qubit corrisponde a un punto unico sulla
sfera, e ogni punto sulla sfera rappresenta uno stato di qubit unico a meno di una fase globale. Quando lavoriamo con
vettori di stato quantistico. Questa corrispondenza va anche sotto altri nomi, tra l'altro: viene anche talvolta chiamata sfera di Poincaré per
esempio, ma nel contesto dell'informazione quantistica viene generalmente denominata sfera di Bloch. Nota che ora possiamo vedere la
degenerazione nell'angolo φ abbastanza chiaramente, perché la longitudine non ha significato ai Poli Nord e Sud. Ma a parte
i poli ogni punto sulla Terra ha coordinate uniche in termini di latitudine e longitudine, e la stessa cosa accade qui. Quindi ecco come
funziona la sfera di Bloch in generale. Ora diamo un'occhiata ad alcuni esempi specifici di stati di qubit e
dove si trovano sulla sfera di Bloch. Iniziamo con la base standard. Questi sono i punti che otteniamo
quando l'angolo polare θ è zero per lo stato zero e π per lo stato uno. Questi sono i due casi in cui
l'angolo azimutale φ è irrilevante, come ho già discusso. Possiamo anche esprimere le corrispondenti matrici densità come combinazioni lineari
di matrici di Pauli in entrambi i modi, e concludiamo che questi due stati corrispondono al Polo Nord e al
Polo Sud della sfera di Bloch. Lo stato zero è in cima e lo stato uno è in
basso. Successivamente troviamo gli stati plus e minus sulla sfera di Bloch. Di nuovo possiamo pensare ai
vettori di stato quantistico o alle matrici densità. Per i vettori di stato quantistico questa volta l'angolo polare θ deve essere π/2
per fare in modo che l'elemento zero sia 1/√2. L'angolo azimutale φ deve essere zero
per lo stato plus perché l'elemento uno è positivo per lo stato plus, e deve essere π o 180° per lo stato minus
perché quello è negativo in quel caso. Quindi questi due punti si trovano sull'
equatore della sfera di Bloch. Lo stato plus è dove l'asse x positivo interseca la sfera, e lo stato minus è sul lato opposto dove
l'asse x negativo interseca la sfera. Equivalentemente possiamo vedere dalle espressioni con le matrici di Pauli per le
corrispondenti matrici densità che le coordinate y e z sono entrambe zero mentre le coordinate x sono rispettivamente +1 e −1.
Un altro esempio è la base plus-I minus-I, che è simile alla base plus-minus tranne che moltiplichiamo anche l'
elemento uno per i, l'unità immaginaria. Abbiamo visto lo stato plus-I prima nella lezione, e lo stato minus-I è definito
in modo analogo. L'angolo polare θ è lo stesso di quello per gli stati plus e minus: π/2,
e questa volta dobbiamo scegliere l'angolo azimutale φ in modo da ottenere i e -i piuttosto che 1 e -1.
π/2 e 3π/2 sono le scelte giuste per farlo. Ancora una volta possiamo anche guardare alle
descrizioni in matrice densità di questi stati, e le cose sono abbastanza simili ai due esempi precedenti tranne che questa volta è la matrice di Pauli Y al posto
di Z o X. Quindi sulla sfera di Bloch questi due stati si trovano dove l'asse y
interseca la sfera. E se riordiniamo un po' possiamo vedere più chiaramente come i sei stati appena discussi
si relazionano tra loro. Per un ultimo esempio, o meglio una classe di esempi, considera i
vettori di stato di qubit che sono emersi prima e nella lezione quattro, dove l'elemento zero è coseno di α per qualche numero reale α e l'elemento
uno è il seno di α. Possiamo, a proposito, limitare la nostra attenzione ai valori di α tra zero e π perché qualsiasi
le descrizioni con matrici densità di questi stati e le cose sono molto simili ai due esempi precedenti, tranne che questa volta è la matrice di Pauli Y al posto
di Z o X. Quindi sulla sfera di Bloch questi due stati si trovano dove l'asse Y
interseca la sfera. E se sistemiamo un po' le cose, possiamo vedere più chiaramente come i sei stati appena discussi
si relazionano tra loro. Per un ultimo esempio, o davvero una classe di esempi, consideriamo i
vettori di stato qubit che sono comparsi prima e nella Lezione Quattro, dove la componente zero è coseno di alfa per un numero reale alfa e la componente
Se calcoliamo le matrici densità associate a questi stati espresse come combinazioni lineari delle matrici di Pauli,
otteniamo l'espressione mostrata sullo schermo. Quel calcolo non è mostrato qui ma è quello che dovresti
ottenere se lo fai. E quello che troviamo è che questi stati formano quello che si chiama un cerchio massimo che passa
attraverso i poli. Specificatamente, partendo dal Polo Nord quando α è zero, scendendo lungo il meridiano zero e
raggiungendo il Polo Sud quando α è π/2, e poi tornando al Polo Nord sul lato opposto della sfera mentre α varia da π/2 a
π. E tutto ciò ha senso perché in primo luogo questi sono vettori reali, quindi la parte immaginaria è sempre zero, e in secondo luogo
l'angolo α viene effettivamente raddoppiato sulla sfera di Bloch, e ancora una volta questo si spiega con l'uso
delle formule del doppio angolo. Abbiamo visto che la sfera di Bloch fornisce una rappresentazione geometrica molto bella per gli stati puri di un
qubit, dove ogni punto sulla sfera corrisponde a uno stato puro unico di un qubit e viceversa.
Quando ci riferiamo alla palla di Bloch parliamo di tutti i punti sulla sfera di Bloch nonché dei punti
contenuti al suo interno. I punti nell'interno della palla di Bloch corrispondono anch'essi a stati di qubit,
specificatamente stati che non sono puri. In altri termini, questi sono stati di qubit che possono essere rappresentati da matrici densità ma non da vettori di stato di qubit.
Un aspetto fondamentale della palla di Bloch e del modo in cui i punti interni rappresentano gli stati impuri è che
le combinazioni convesse di punti all'interno della palla di Bloch corrispondono a combinazioni convesse di matrici densità.
Intuitivamente questo significa che la geometria continua a funzionare perfettamente anche all'interno della palla di
Bloch. Diamo un'occhiata a un paio di esempi, iniziando con il punto centrale della palla di Bloch che rappresenta lo stato completamente
misto. Lo stato completamente misto si ottiene facendo la media degli stati zero e uno, il che è coerente con il fatto
che il centro della sfera è esattamente a metà strada tra il Polo Nord e il Polo Sud. E in effetti è a metà strada tra qualsiasi coppia di punti antipodali, come
gli stati plus e minus e gli stati plus-I e minus-I. I punti antipodali nella sfera di Bloch corrispondono sempre a
stati puri ortogonali. E quello che questo rivela o riflette è che possiamo sempre scrivere lo stato completamente misto
come media tra due qualsiasi stati puri di qubit ortogonali. Un altro modo per vederlo è
pensare alla rappresentazione con le matrici di Pauli dello stato completamente misto. Per fare questo dobbiamo impostare
i coefficienti di tutte e tre le matrici di Pauli non identità a zero, e quindi il corrispondente punto all'interno della
palla di Bloch è proprio al centro, nell'origine. E a proposito, pensare alle rappresentazioni con le matrici di Pauli delle matrici
densità in questo modo rende in effetti abbastanza chiaro che le combinazioni convesse di punti della palla di Bloch corrispondono a combinazioni
convesse di matrici densità. Se prendiamo una media o una media ponderata di matrici densità e
esprimiamo tutto in termini di combinazioni lineari delle matrici di Pauli, ovviamente stiamo solo facendo la media dei punti corrispondenti perché tutto è
lineare in quei tre coefficienti. Per un altro esempio, consideriamo la media dello stato zero
e dello stato plus, che abbiamo visto prima nella lezione. Abbiamo calcolato la rappresentazione in matrice densità mostrata sullo
schermo, e abbiamo che il punto si trova nell'interno della palla di Bloch a metà strada tra lo stato zero e lo stato plus.
Abbiamo anche visto che potevamo esprimere questa matrice densità in modo diverso basandoci sulla sua decomposizione spettrale, e
anche questo è coerente con il diagramma e gli esempi precedenti. E questo conclude la
discussione della sfera di Bloch e della palla di Bloch. Le persone spesso chiedono se esiste una sfera di Bloch o palla di Bloch per sistemi con
tre o più stati classici, e la risposta purtroppo è non proprio. Possiamo sempre pensare agli
stati quantistici di un sistema in termini geometrici simili alla palla di Bloch e otteniamo un corpo convesso in uno spazio vettoriale reale,
ma se abbiamo tre o più stati classici non sarà sferico. Per esempio se abbiamo
esattamente tre stati classici, ovvero un qutrit, otteniamo un corpo convesso in uno spazio
otto-dimensionale, ma i punti estremi di quel corpo che corrispondono agli stati quantistici puri di un qutrit saranno solo
quattro-dimensionali. Se riesci a visualizzare una varietà quattro-dimensionale in uno spazio otto-dimensionale e a immaginare di avvolgerla in una pellicola trasparente per ottenere un corpo
convesso e trovi che questo sia un modo utile di pensare ai qutrit, bene per te. È interessante pensarci
ma non è una palla: è più complicato di così. Nella parte finale della lezione discuteremo brevemente
come le matrici densità funzionano per sistemi multipli. Le matrici densità possono rappresentare stati di sistemi multipli e questo
funziona in modo completamente analogo ai vettori di stato quantistico. In particolare, proprio come abbiamo nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica,
possiamo vedere più sistemi insieme come se fossero un singolo sistema composto.
Questa volta sia le righe che le colonne delle matrici densità che rappresentano stati di sistemi multipli sono
messe in corrispondenza con il prodotto cartesiano degli insiemi di stati classici dei singoli sistemi. Per esempio possiamo considerare
le rappresentazioni in matrice densità dei quattro stati di Bell, che otteniamo precisamente come abbiamo fatto per altri vettori di stato
quantistico prima nella lezione, moltiplicando i vettori di stato per le loro trasposte coniugate. I risultati sono mostrati qui sullo
schermo. In sostanza non c'è nulla di nuovo a livello concettuale, anche se vedremo tra poco che ci sono alcune
cose nuove che possiamo fare con le matrici densità per sistemi multipli. Le nozioni di indipendenza e
correlazioni si trasferiscono dai vettori di stato quantistico alle matrici densità, e in particolare troviamo che i prodotti tensoriali
di matrici densità rappresentano l'indipendenza tra sistemi. Usiamo la stessa terminologia che
abbiamo usato per i vettori di stato quantistico. Per esempio, se abbiamo un sistema X preparato in uno stato ρ e un sistema Y
preparato indipendentemente in uno stato σ, allora lo stato della coppia XY insieme è dato dal prodotto tensoriale
di ρ e σ. Chiamiamo questo uno stato prodotto e si generalizza in modo naturale a più di due
sistemi. Le matrici densità che non possono essere espresse come stati prodotto rappresentano correlazioni tra sistemi, e questa
parte è simile ai vettori di stato quantistico. Ma come risulta, ci sono diversi tipi di correlazioni che possono emergere quando usiamo le matrici densità, anche per
soli due sistemi. Al contrario, c'è davvero solo un tipo di correlazione che possiamo avere per i vettori di stato quantistico, e
cioè l'entanglement. Per dirla in un altro modo, correlazione ed entanglement sono sinonimi per i vettori di stato quantistico, ma
non è vero per le matrici densità. Qui le cose sono più interessanti. Per esempio possiamo descrivere
stati classici correlati con le matrici densità. Ecco un esempio di una matrice densità che rappresenta un bit casuale classico
WEBVTT
condiviso tra Alice e Bob. Hanno sempre lo stesso stato classico, zero o uno, e la probabilità è
1/2 per ciascuna delle possibilità. Questo non è uno stato entangled: l'entanglement è non classico, ma
è uno stato correlato. Un altro esempio è connesso alla nozione di ensemble di stati quantistici,
che puoi pensare come una distribuzione di probabilità su un insieme finito di stati quantistici. In particolare, immaginiamo di
avere M matrici densità ρ₀ fino a ρ_, tutte che rappresentano possibili stati di un particolare sistema,
insieme a una probabilità per estrarre ciascuna di esse. Se volessimo potremmo calcolare la media ponderata di queste matrici densità
prendendo una combinazione convessa di esse, ma questo non ci direbbe effettivamente quali fossero i singoli stati o quali
fossero le probabilità. Quello che possiamo fare invece, ed è abbastanza utile farlo a volte, è considerare una matrice
densità della forma mostrata qui sullo schermo. Questo è uno stato di due sistemi in cui il primo sistema ha uno stato classico per
ciascuna delle alternative, e prendiamo la media ponderata di M stati prodotto in cui lo stato del
primo sistema è sempre classico e fondamentalmente etichetta quale degli M stati abbiamo per il secondo
sistema. Se non è chiaro esattamente perché vorremmo pensare a stati come questo, va bene: è solo un esempio di
un tipo di correlazione in cui il primo sistema è sempre classico e il secondo sistema può essere in uno stato
quantistico. Una terza categoria di stati possibilmente correlati è l'insieme dei cosiddetti stati
separabili. In termini semplici, questi sono combinazioni convesse di stati prodotto ed essenzialmente rappresentano stati quantistici
in cui eventuali correlazioni tra i sistemi sono correlazioni classiche. Un modo per pensare a stati
come questi è che facciamo una selezione probabilistica per un numero K e poi prepariamo indipendentemente due
sistemi in uno stato quantistico che può dipendere da questa scelta di K. La cosa forse più interessante di
stati di questa forma è che questo è in realtà il modo in cui definiamo l'entanglement in termini matematici. In particolare l'entanglement è
definito come mancanza di separabilità. Quindi se hai una matrice densità e non è possibile esprimerla in una forma
come questa, allora per definizione è entangled. Ho accennato a questo nella lezione quattro e qui lo vediamo con un po' più di
dettaglio. A proposito, può essere molto difficile capire se una data matrice densità rappresenta uno stato
entangled, anche con l'aiuto di un computer. Matematicamente e computazionalmente parlando, l'entanglement è
in realtà piuttosto complicato. Ho menzionato all'inizio della lezione che c'è una cosa molto importante che possiamo fare con le matrici densità, e
cioè descrivere gli stati di parti isolate di sistemi anche quando sono correlate e possibilmente entangled con altri
sistemi. Il termine stato ridotto è spesso usato in questo contesto e, come esempio semplice, calcoleremo gli stati ridotti
per i singoli qubit che formano un ebit. Per essere precisi, supponiamo che
Alice e Bob condividano un ebit: Alice tiene un qubit A, Bob tiene un qubit B, e insieme questi due qubit sono nello stato φ
plus. La domanda che affronteremo è: qual è lo stato del qubit A di Alice in
isolamento? Ovviamente potremmo porre la stessa domanda per il qubit di Bob, ma è facile rispondere a quella domanda una volta che conosciamo la risposta a questa.
Ora potrebbe essere tentante dire che non possiamo descrivere lo stato del qubit di Alice in isolamento perché è
entangled con il qubit di Bob, il che potrebbe in qualche modo impedirci di descrivere o anche solo pensare allo stato di A in
isolamento. Ma questo è falso. È vero che non possiamo descrivere lo stato di A con un vettore di stato quantistico,
perché come vedremo non è in uno stato puro. Ma ogni sistema ha uno stato in qualsiasi momento che può essere
descritto da una matrice densità, che sia entangled con un altro sistema o meno. Come esperimento mentale, solo per aiutarci
a capire qual è la risposta a questa domanda, supponiamo che Bob decida di prendere il suo qubit e viaggiare verso le stelle, e da lui non si sente
più. Ma immagina che da qualche parte lungo la strada decida di eseguire una misura nella base standard sul suo
qubit. Sappiamo come calcolare le probabilità che lui ottenga i due possibili esiti, e sappiamo anche qual è lo
stato di A per ciascun possibile esito, e queste cose sono riassunte in questa tabella. In particolare, con probabilità 1/2
A verrà lasciato nello stato zero, e con probabilità 1/2 A verrà lasciato nello stato uno. E quindi, come discusso prima nella
lezione, questo lascia A nello stato completamente misto. E quindi questa è la risposta
alla nostra domanda. Ora potresti obiettare dicendo che questo dipende dal fatto che Bob ha deciso di misurare il suo qubit e che
l'assunzione che lo faccia è parte della storia che ci ha portato a questa risposta. Ma
se Bob è ad anni luce di distanza nel momento in cui misura, niente di quello che fa potrebbe avere alcuna influenza su qualsiasi
esperimento che Alice potrebbe decidere di eseguire sul suo qubit, altrimenti avremmo una comunicazione
più veloce della luce. Quindi il qubit di Alice è nello stato completamente misto indipendentemente dal fatto che Bob
misuri o meno. Dovrei chiarire a questo punto che la nozione di stato ridotto e il modo in cui viene definita non ha davvero alcuna dipendenza dalla relatività
o dall'impossibilità della comunicazione più veloce della luce. Questo è solo un modo per spiegarlo in termini che si spera siano intuitivi.
In realtà c'è una definizione matematica che vedremo in un contesto più generale tra poco. È coerente con questa risposta
e coincidentalmente con l'impossibilità della comunicazione più veloce della luce. E non c'è altra
definizione che possa essere coerente con l'informazione quantistica come la conosciamo. Ora consideriamo gli stati ridotti in maggiore
generalità. Supponiamo di avere una coppia di sistemi A e B, non necessariamente qubit, che sono insieme in uno stato puro
rappresentato da un vettore di stato quantistico ψ. Di nuovo ci concentreremo sullo stato ridotto del sistema A e, per fare
questo, sarà utile pensare agli stati classici del sistema B. Quindi sia Γ l'insieme di
stati classici di B. Come abbiamo discusso prima, nella seconda lezione della serie per esempio,
esiste una collezione unica di vettori φ_b per ciascun b in Γ per cui l'espressione di ψ mostrata sullo schermo è
corretta. E in particolare c'è una formula semplice per questi vettori: semplicemente moltiplichiamo il vettore ψ per il
prodotto tensoriale della matrice identità corrispondente al sistema A con bra-b per qualunque b ci interessi.
Quello che stiamo facendo qui è fondamentalmente prepararci a calcolare quello che succederebbe se eseguissimo una misura nella base standard
su B, e di nuovo questo è stato trattato nella seconda lezione della serie.
quello che stiamo facendo qui è fondamentalmente prepararci a calcolare cosa succederebbe se dovessimo eseguire una
misura nella base standard su B, e di nuovo questo è stato trattato nella seconda lezione della
serie. Quindi supponiamo di eseguire una misura nella base standard su B. Ciascun possibile esito apparirebbe
con probabilità uguale al quadrato della norma euclidea del corrispondente vettore φ_b, e condizionatamente all'ottenimento di un
particolare esito b normalizziamo il vettore φ_b per determinare lo stato risultante di
A. Seguendo lo stesso ragionamento dell'esempio dell'ebit di poco fa, otteniamo l'espressione mostrata sullo
schermo per lo stato ridotto di A come matrice densità. E a proposito, il quadrato della norma al denominatore deriva dal
fatto che moltiplichiamo il vettore normalizzato per la sua trasposta coniugata, quindi raccogliamo la norma euclidea due volte al
denominatore. I quadrati della norma euclidea si cancellano e rimaniamo con un'espressione abbastanza semplice.
E in effetti se sostituiamo la nostra formula per φ_b, che vale per ogni b, otteniamo una formula per lo stato ridotto
del sistema A in termini della descrizione in matrice densità dello stato puro da cui siamo partiti, cioè ket-ψ bra-ψ.
Questa è quindi la nostra formula per lo stato ridotto del sistema A, supponendo che il sistema composto AB sia iniziato nello
stato puro ψ. Ma possiamo anche usare la formula più in generale. In particolare supponiamo
che lo stato di AB sia dato da una qualche matrice densità ρ, che potrebbe avere la forma ket-ψ bra-ψ per qualche vettore di stato quantistico ψ
ma non necessariamente. Ne segue sostanzialmente per linearità che lo stato ridotto di A è
determinato dalla stessa formula che avevamo per gli stati puri, tranne che sostituiamo qualunque matrice densità ρ vogliamo.
Come notazione abbreviata è abbastanza comune che denotiamo questo stato ridotto con qualunque nome stiamo usando per la
matrice densità ρ in questo caso, ma mettiamo un pedice che indica il sistema su cui ci stiamo concentrando. Quindi ρ con
pedice A significa lo stato ridotto di A quando il sistema composto è nello stato ρ. A volte si usano anche gli apici
al posto dei pedici: è sostanzialmente solo una preferenza personale e significa la stessa
cosa. Ci siamo concentrati sul sistema A solo per semplicità, ma possiamo anche ottenere lo stato ridotto del sistema B
in modo analogo, dove la formula è adattata nel modo naturale. Tutto è simmetrico qui: stiamo
essenzialmente solo scambiando i ruoli di A e B, e in particolare la somma si estende ora sugli stati classici di A questa volta
piuttosto che di B, e nella formula sullo schermo stiamo assumendo che l'insieme di stati classici di A si chiami
Σ. Tutto questo si generalizza in modo abbastanza diretto a tre o più sistemi. Per esempio se abbiamo tre
sistemi A, B e C che sono collettivamente nello stato descritto dalla matrice densità ρ, allora possiamo ottenere lo
stato ridotto della coppia AB insieme con la formula mostrata qui, nonché lo stato del terzo sistema da solo
con la seconda formula. E puoi considerare altre combinazioni e generalizzare questo a quanti sistemi vuoi. Le somme sono sempre prese sugli
insiemi di stati classici dei sistemi che vengono ignorati, e il pattern è sempre lo stesso: la matrice densità con cui
siamo partiti viene sandwichata tra il prodotto tensoriale della matrice identità e i bra e ket corrispondenti agli stati della base standard.
Per concludere la lezione dirò solo qualcosa in più sulle definizioni che abbiamo appena trattato. L'operazione sulle matrici densità
che descrive gli stati ridotti ha un nome ed è chiamata traccia parziale. Per due sistemi A e B, la
traccia parziale su B e la traccia parziale su A sono come definite qui sullo schermo. Queste sono esattamente le stesse
formule che abbiamo visto poco fa, e ora le stiamo solo considerando come funzioni di ρ e dando loro
dei nomi. I nomi sembrano la traccia tranne che c'è un pedice che ci dice quale sistema viene rimosso,
ovvero quale sistema è quello il cui insieme di stati classici stiamo sommando e che viene sandwichato tra un bra e un
ket. Quando prendiamo la traccia parziale di ρ su B per esempio, che è descritta dalla prima formula, a volte diciamo che
B viene traced out, e lo stesso per A. Intuitivamente parlando, "fare la traccia" di un
sistema significa semplicemente buttarlo via o ignorarlo. Questo è un modo per definire la traccia
parziale, e un altro modo equivalente è dire che queste mappature sono le uniche mappature lineari che soddisfano le
formule mostrate qui a destra. Specificatamente, se abbiamo un prodotto tensoriale di due matrici M ed N diciamo,
e eseguiamo la traccia parziale sul primo sistema, quello che otteniamo è la traccia della prima matrice M per
la seconda matrice. E la condizione è simmetrica quando facciamo la traccia sul secondo sistema. Non ogni matrice di cui vorremmo calcolare la traccia parziale è un prodotto tensoriale come questo, ma ogni matrice può essere espressa come combinazione lineare di
prodotti tensoriali, e possiamo determinare la traccia parziale da queste condizioni insieme al fatto che queste sono funzioni lineari.
Ed è per questo che si chiama traccia parziale. Questa definizione equivalente può essere
abbastanza utile perché spesso possiamo usarla al posto della formula originale. Ecco un esempio che
illustra questo. Supponiamo di avere una coppia di qubit nello stato la cui matrice densità è mostrata qui sullo
schermo. Questo si trova essere un esempio di uno stato correlato in cui A è o nello stato zero o nello stato uno, ciascuno con
probabilità 1/2. Quindi possiamo pensare ad A come classico. Se A è nello stato zero allora lo è anche
B, e se A è nello stato uno allora B è nello stato plus. Se vogliamo sapere qual è lo stato ridotto di A
facciamo la traccia su B, e se usiamo la seconda formula dalla definizione equivalente insieme alla linearità allora possiamo
calcolarlo abbastanza facilmente. In particolare la traccia di ket-0 bra-0 è uno, come lo è la traccia di ket-plus bra-plus,
quindi quei fattori tensoriali scompaiono e rimaniamo con lo stato completamente misto. Allo stesso modo possiamo calcolare
lo stato ridotto di B facendo la traccia su A. Questa volta è il primo fattore tensoriale su cui eseguiamo la traccia, quindi
stiamo usando la prima formula dalla definizione equivalente, e rimaniamo con 1/2 per ket-0 bra-0 più 1/2 per ket-plus bra-plus,
ovvero in altre parole la stessa matrice densità che è emersa alcune volte precedentemente. Otterresti esattamente gli stessi
risultati se usassi le formule della prima definizione, ma questo è un modo molto più semplice per farlo. Tutto questo si generalizza a tre o più
sistemi, ma per questo video mi fermo qui e lascio questo a te da considerare per conto tuo. E questo è tutto per questa lezione che
ha introdotto le matrici densità e descritto le basi del loro funzionamento. Abbiamo anche discusso la sfera di Bloch
nonché diversi tipi di correlazioni e la nozione di stato ridotto di un sistema. Spero che tu voglia
unirti a me per la prossima lezione, che riguarda i canali, ovvero le mappature lineari dalle matrici densità alle matrici densità che
descrivono le operazioni sui sistemi. Arrivederci alla
WEBVTT
prossima lezione.
Ciao.